yeah welcome to new video and play you
for for a change against play debt from
the UK at least that's the flag and we
got tonight off yeah I normally play
this kind of line leading to a more
positional I'm battle I'm not one for
player really I'm playing it in those
videos to have some variety but i don't
really know the the lines yeah 96 some
not a very typical night off move I'd
like to prevent b5 for a while the abbey
should be six wants to be expected and
so what term what now is some f4 right
IAM on f4 he may be can can take and
play d 5 which would really am simplify
the position known a lot Bishop g5 he
can play Knight takes e4 others typical
tactic and what else is there can play
Bishop f3 yeah maybe Bishop f3 impotent
looks it's the very strange sort of
strategical move that it doesn't really
doesn't really do much
maybe maybe i can even allow the 5d 5
takes Knight takes Knight eggs and then
95 maybe yes still maybe maybe a t5 must
be it's only the principal move let's
put it this way but well he can always
play whoopsie ATM or something that sir
yeah that's certainly am certainly an
option so one is a foreign idea and with
a flair for it takes effort Bishop f4 so
is just a temple loss okay come on let's
prevent e5 this really looks like em it
would would solve all of blacks problems
if he gets in d5 but it is very very
slow well this is always an option
trying to support d5
yeah maybe this one on d5 I have Bishop
c5 which isn't I don't know you should
be six months you have of course d5
Bishop Bishop to b6 an option um which
isn't the end of the world for black
yeah this son is certainly not a
position that can scab like I mean this
this much is clear came yeah his evening
is his evil am intending to take b6 so
it's questionable of this this whole
maneuver really led to anything probably
it was just just bogus how to play maybe
I need to to attack in five he takes on
b6 I'm hoping that at least the bishop
on a 3 provides some counter play em
against the b7 pawn if this is not
working out that I'm really in bad shape
okay he goes for this and I saw that I
mean but I didn't really saw what what
he's doing now would be seven ok we can
probably can maybe ignore it and say
okay I'll get them get-get b6 and so on
you know because this is immediately
hanging this is the problem
and yeah this wasn't wasn't great
maybe this relatively best
hmm is it so awful really I mean okay it
cannot be great for me this is clear but
maybe I get at least a bit of play here
it's not easy to to keep the pawn if I
get p6 p7 and don't immediately lose v6
or something then this is fun maybe even
quite okay hmm yeah of course I'm my
absolute non knowledge of the opening
was I wasn't wasn't helping much I was
instantly worse after a couple of moves
so what now I cannot attack anything
with bishop at the night for example of
the bishop I just take next move on b7
and maybe this is this is even ok for me
the be porn is dangerous ok I can take
em now I'm threatening knight c6 even I
threatened 96 ok
how to proceed here there's some some
tactics going on don't still see any
okay let's take this I actually
completely forgot about that you can't
exchange to look immediately so slightly
annoying and this was a strange choice
maybe it is still winning but I wouldn't
go to the opposite color bishops ending
here in a million years and maybe know
if force is working that's of course the
the opposite the wrong color term bishop
is the problem runcorn h5 weird
yeah I managed okay I'm not sure maybe
maybe if I flake this is really lost so
impossible I can go to hmm I mean this
is lost young player I don't get get
into the corner yeah probably then then
this whole thing is losing something
else here maybe okay it's it's a bit I
just thought it was a weird decision to
learn to to get to the opposite colored
bishops and game simply because bishop d
forum is just winning in the long run
with the two bishops but maybe it is the
easiest to to do to do that okay dumb
the opening simply and was what's the
disaster and this year is probably a
probably still very good for black well
I don't really have any way to to
improve here maybe n yeah but Knight
takes cannot be the solution either it's
probably bed all along I just thought
that maybe this this would help but I
cannot I don't have a moose in this
position if I am play as some slow move
King g1 or something he just approaches
with the King I can never move this
Bishop sp6 is falling I cannot move the
light because it needs to protect be
seven so I don't really have a move yeah
thanks for watching